بشكل عام الغناء العربي
بالوثائق الوثائق يا اما تدوينات مكتوبه
يعني او نقول له تسجيلات صوتيه
لم يتح لنا تسجيل الصوت الا في القرن
العشرين ومن هنا صار في فرصه لحفظ الصوت
البشري بالاضافه طبعا الى حفظ ايضا صوت
العزف
وتقنيه التسجيل المختلفه طبعا بديتم يعني
من اشكال الاستديو
واشكال الحافظه الاسطوانات الشمعيه والحجر
وما الى ذلك يعني حتى التطورها يعني الى
الان الى الام بي 3 يعني او التقنيات اللي
بتوفر التسجيلات الصوتيه وما غيرها
فبالتالي الاغنيه مربوطه بالوثيقه الصوتيه
من دونها مثل التمثيل من دون موسيقى بصريه
لا نعرف من كان يمثل او كيف كان يمثل نفس
الشيء من كان يغني وكيف كان يغني يعني
مثلا كتاب او الكتب اللي دونات الغناء
العربي الكثيره يعني
طبعا اشارها عند الناس اللي هو كتاب
الاغاني للاصحاني وفي كتب اخرى طبعا فيما
بعد استمرت بنفس الطريقه للتدوين نحن نقرا
نصوص ونقرا وصف لكن لا نسمع اصوات
ولا نسمع اصوات الات فقط نقرا نصوص القرن
العشرين اتاح لنا وثائق صوتيه
وهذه بدايه الاسطوانات
والتسجيلات طبعا بالاضافه الى طبعا
الوسائل الاخرى عالميه مهمه ايضا الاذاعات
الاهليه لفترتها يعني بعد الحرب العالميه
الاولى قبل كل اذاعات رسميه طبعا الامر
الثاني ايضا ظهرت شركات الانتاج المختلفه
اللي ساهمت طبعا بالاضافه الى مؤسسات
حكوميه ايضا ساهمت الاغنيه السعوديه
الاغنيه هذا مصطلح طبعا لا يعادل كلمه
الغناء الغناء هذا مصطلح اخر الاغنيه
السعوديه نقول ارخت من رحله طارق عبد
الحكيم الى القاهره في منتصف مؤسسه
الخمسينات انه هو من فكر في وضع ما يسمى
بالاغنيه السعوديه
للمعيار اللي كان منتشر من مركزين احنا في
بدايه القرن العشرين بالذات يعني في مرحله
العشرينات والثلاثينات بغداد والقاهره هم
الاولاني فيما بعد تزعم المركزين في
الستينات بيروت والكويت
استفاد طارق انه مركز القاهره كان جاهز
تجهيزاته طبعا وامكانياته والعازفين ولانه
هو بحكم انه يشتغل في المجال العسكري لا
يمكن ان يسجل بصوته فاستعان باصوات
السيدات المغنيات العربيات في القاهره
وبدات هنا ولاده الاغنيه
او 55 مع اصوات نجاح سلام وفايزه احمد
يعني بعدين حدث تغيير سياسي انتقلوا
للتسجيل في بيروت وايضا استمر يسجل مع
المغنيين اللبنانيين والمغنيات وديع
الصافي وصباح وسميره توفيق
ومشى في قطاع طبعا مجموعه في منهم من
استطاع ان يسافر مثل طعام مداح
وفي منهم انتظر حتى ظهور الاذاعات
السعوديه وسجل فيها طبعا يعني
ومن هنا استمرت يعني فالاسس اللي وضعها
طارق بما فيها طبعا تاسيسه لما يسمى مدرسه
موسيقات الجيش العربي السعودي اللي يعني
كانت مسؤوله من اجل تاسيس فرقه موسيقى
عسكريه في السعوديه
واللي هي طبعا كانت نواه الفرقه الموسيقيه
في الاذاعه مع كوادر اخرى من الدول
العربيه
فطارق هو ابو الاغنيه السعوديه
انقلب عليه بسرعه يعني